ja wir haben es gerade schon gesagt wer
nicht wer das ist so eine frage da
möchte man sich gar nicht so richtig
darauf festlegen
herr leggewie ist da ihre meinung dazu
sollte man die im freien folge
abschaffen
also es ist wohin das wort pragmatismus
gefallen und ich glaube das ist ganz
zentral das ist das was wir jetzt
brauchen
man kann sich lange an dem thema
gerechtigkeit eine impf reihenfolge
festhalten und sagen das ist er der
wichtigste gesichtspunkt von allen aber
wenn wir insgesamt noch feststellen
müssen wir haben probleme damit mit der
distribution der wir kriegen des
impfstoff nicht ausreichend schnell
genug feuer verhilft um aus dieser
pandemie auszukommen
wenn wir sehen im vergleich zu anderen
ländern geht es deutlich langsamer voran
dann muss man etwas ändern und insofern
bin ich der meinung dass man tatsächlich
diese in rio regierung grundsätzlich
abschaffen sollte ich würde es anders
machen und und gerade auch wie es in
manchen ländern gemacht wird zum
beispiel israel dass man einfach erstmal
in ganz anderen also locations in
einsamen orten impft die israelis haben
das in bars gemacht und und ganz
pragmatisch mit wir müssen das nicht
alles im impfzentrum machen und man
sollte auch sehen wenn man eben mit mit
den 80 jährigen
da sind wir im moment ja immer noch wenn
man damit nicht schnell genug vorankommt
dann sollte man auch auf jeden fall
schon mal andere impfen
gerade auch wenn ihm klose noch da sie
vielen dank für die antwort erstmal da
möchte ich gerne noch stephan zenger
begrüßen bürgermeister aus plauen herz
erhält grad gerade gesagt wenn es nach
ihm ginge würde er die priorisierung
abschaffen bei ihnen ist das jetzt so in
plauen sind sie darüber glücklich oder
ist das eher so eine organisatorische
aufgabe weil sie jetzt schauen müssen wo
einfach der impfstoff herkommt
herzlichen gruß in die runde tatsächlich
sind wir und laden sehr glücklich
darüber
wir haben seit monaten eine inzidenz
weit über 250 und wir sehen am ende des
horizonts es kein licht und deshalb ist
es für uns ein sehr gutes zeichen zu
sagen wir wollen die prioritätenliste
aufheben wir selber vertrauen darauf
dass genügend impfstoff geliefert wird
wir sind als kreisangehörige stadt
plauen nicht in der lage den impfstoff
zuvor tatsächlich zu regeln aber für uns
ganz wichtig auch noch mal in die runde
es ist nicht so dass sich die vogtländer
nicht an die korona ringe zeiten also
wir haben seit monaten stehen da wir
halten uns daran aber wir haben eben
tatsächlich viele auspendler nach
franken und thüringen und gerade um klar
oben sind die institute auch sehr hoch
und wir haben sehr sehr viele einpendler
aus tschechien und diese ein könnte das
sind arbeitskräfte die bei uns in den
betrieben arbeiten aber auch in den
einrichtungen arbeiten in den
krankenhäusern arbeiten wir glauben
diese diese personen um auch unsere
infrastruktur am leben zu erhalten und
diese faktoren sind es tatsächlich die
eben dann diese hohen in sidenten nach
sich ziehen
herr frage an sie was halten sie denn
persönlich von diesem konzept der
bundesregierung der der priorisierung
also ich hätte es anders gemacht muss
ich ganz klar sagen ich meine wir müssen
mal zuerst auch wenn man einen schritt
drückt sollte muss man ja auch darauf
hinweisen dass die fehler die erst nicht
die einzigen aber die ersten fehler sind
ja letztes jahr gemacht worden
man kann nicht drumherum zu erkennen
dass frau merkel ersparen und andere
verantwortliche einfach viel viel zu
wenig impfstoff bestellt haben und da
kommen wir nicht drum herum diese
erkenntnis und das ist ein massiver
fehler gewesen und ein fehler den man
auch durchaus noch hätte auch schneller
korrigieren können also so biden hat ja
auch nach amtsantritt auch noch mal
deutlich nach bestellt von denen ohnehin
vielen dies da gab aber dann zu sagen
wir halten strikt und zwar jetzt
mittlerweile wie impfen ja seit
weihnachten jetzt seit monaten immer
noch an die
der priorisierung fest obwohl wir sehen
müssen dass sie nicht gut funktioniert
wurden war ein beispiel genannt wurden
in regensburg 83-jährige auf meine
mutter die ist 79 einhalb ist auch noch
nicht in dieser gruppe der 80 gegen die
geimpft werden sollen ich habe auch
bisher keinen impftermin dass es in
niedersachsen
also man muss einfach jetzt vorangehen
denn sonst was was passiert ist nämlich
auch viel viel schlimmeres als nur dass
die info mich voran gehen wir sehen ja
jetzt hier auch an den fällen dass
menschen schuldige suchen
man versucht das fest zu machen an den
pendlern oder an anderen die das
einstecken um auch zu sagen ja die
menschen im land sind es nicht gewesen
was ich auch nicht glaube und das liegt
daran dass man hier auch von seiten der
bundesregierung immer wieder ja seit
beginn der krise die an diesen instanzen
alles fest macht das wo was übrigens
auch ein herr laschet mittlerweile sagt
was wir nicht tun sollten und wir müssen
uns endlich verabschieden von diesen
instanzen als zahl und handfestere
kriterien wie zum beispiel belegung von
intensiv kapazitäten und so etwas als
als kriterien nehmen und und dann fahren
wir besser mit dieser politik
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren